all right so listen i have two sons of
cops here yeah that's true that's
a weird coincidence but you smoke as
much weed as i did tonight no i don't
think
i'm gonna keep that off the record
that's me over here i'm the one who
smokes it when you shoot
so
look journalists you guys get a lot of
[ __ ] i got to say sometimes boy
they do some really great stuff they
went undercover sort of and found out
that police killings in america have
been under counted because this is
buried in the statistics up until very
recently like two weeks ago when the
story came out we thought police
killings in america were the
i was going by the stats that the fbi
gave us
well about 55 of fatal encounters
between 1980 and 2018 were listed as
another cause of death when it was
really the cops the main reason
the uh medical examiners
were covering up for them
you know they were they work in the same
office
it's like when your buddy breaks the
copier and you cut a cup you know
and so
we we thought
17 000 people were killed it was
actually 31 000 and of course a stark
racial gap 3.5 times as likely to be
killed as a black american as a white by
the cops so
i mean there's a lot to that story but i
was one of the reaction of two guys who
whose dad's working well you need to
bring more of this data out into the
light it's appalling that the washington
post six years ago had to be the one to
build this whole database on police
killings in this country and so often
when you look at the data too we don't
even know the names of police officers
who are involved with the deaths of
young black men across the country and
as a reporter bring it all out
pull it into the sunlight because you
can't hide from the truth here and the
truth there's always more truth when it
comes to police killings it's evasive
the culture around it and you've got to
keep digging i want to acknowledge it's
not easy being a police officer i don't
think anyone wants to get up and see the
things that i have two cousins that are
currently police officers and with that
said i don't want what happened in
brunswick georgia to happen an ex-cop
can hunt a black man down or any person
with their kid and because they're
friends with the prosecutor just get a
get out of jail free card until people
come in i think that in terms of being
punitive i've often heard politicians
talk about coming down on crime police
officers that are that are guilty of
these crimes should serve no less than
life in jail in terms of murdering
someone police officers that do this
should have their pensions cut off and
paid to the families of those murdered
and the taxpayers don't need to keep
paying these suits off and last but not
least we need to make police officer
training longer than six to eight months
it needs to be like a junior college at
least a couple years and you need to
either be reflective of or come from the
communities you're policing because if
not what you're setting up is a hunter
and prey situation and i think that's
what's driven americans you know
when i was growing up my dad was a cop
in washington dc in the northeast
section of dc my dad i always will
remember this my dad said the greatest
thing he ever did as a police officer is
never had to fire his weapon
that there was that he took pride he
takes pride in that that he never had to
fire his weapon and you just see across
all these cities and communities it's
the escalation constantly that leads to
this and this is just fervor around
tense events a pair could a paraplegic
young man was just drug out of a car
a paraplegic who's telling the cop
my legs don't work it's drug out of a
car we've seen women and mothers it's
time to reform policing in a way that's
punitive to bad cops and in a way that
encourages
from it though in education yeah they
did reform key word yeah as opposed to
defunct i think if you said the word
defund
i think a lot of americans would think
oh that's the position defund the police
of most democratic politicians it's not
it's the position of a lot of democrats
on twitter there was a senator from
alabama tommy tuberville i think he was
a football coach he's a [ __ ]
he
he is he's just a [ __ ] i mean he he
wanted to put senate democrats on the
record to be against
uh or for defunding the police and it
was 99-0 against it so the democratic
politicians are not for defunding the
police
it's the twitter mob that is and this is
the problem the democratic politicians
wear that on them because people don't
make that differentiation and you're not
for defunding the police you said
reforming the police i want to reform
the police but i also would like to move
where money goes in atlanta we had a
wonderful police athletic league it was
putting great kids out there were sports
that were in the boxing that were into
things like um reading after school and
that funding got shrunk and i was
working with them for a while because i
wanted to see more young men learning
how to use their hands and less young
men learning how to use guns on the
streets how rather you better firearms
about taught by a real instructor so i'd
like to see the funding that currently
goes into militarizing police with tanks
and dogs and you know israeli soldier
type training i'd like to see that go
into a different type a different form
in our policing so i'm not saying
because i don't ever think america's
going to defund police but that does not
mean we can't say what our tax dollars
should go to do
you